hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's video is going to be about
how to get the new uh polygons legacy
event loop and how to get that the
fastest so let's get started
so to clarify because lots of people
especially in the stream this morning
we're a bit confused the loop from the
event is the battle outfit the I am war
emote the color swatches and the black
and gold armor and weapons now the black
and gold armor weapons will look
different and have a different name for
everybody so you have to look at the
armor and look at the color and think is
it black and gold then that's probably
the armor this is completely different
from the season 5 weapons they are also
released at the same exact time on the
left is the gladiator event black and
gold weapon and on the right is one of
these season 5 weapon sets 2 completely
totally different things this season 5
weapon sets are never going to go away
but the event loot is for example if I'm
missing one of the I if I'm missing the
I amor emote for Highlander and the
event is over I can't get it anymore if
I do have the emo I keep it forever the
reason I'm making this is because of the
amount of loot that we are given and the
fact that not every match could complete
we get loot from sometimes you get
nothing which is an absolute bummer
hopefully that clears up some confusion
people are having at the start so let's
start on how to get it
so longtime viewers will already know
the answer since I've done this type of
thing on to other events and it's simply
brawl AI you can't receive items in duel
AI so brawl AI is your best option it's
also the fastest game-mode and it
doesn't require a full team maybe just
an extra buddy and since the enemies are
BOTS instead of actual players you can
get matches done in two minutes
I searched the time of 5 matches I
played and got two minutes and 5 seconds
2 minutes 13 two minutes 22 minutes 8
and 2 minutes and 10 seconds I converted
that all to the actual seconds and got
it to 2 minutes and 11 seconds as my
average now I've taken into
consideration this time matchmaking in
teammates if you have a full team before
you can definitely play a tribute a I it
works just as well you can clear tribute
ai matches in about a minute 30 if
you're fast enough giving you tons of
items as well just like with your to do
brawl AI matches lots of people also on
my past videos have told me that regular
duels work just as well but the only
reason I like brawl AI is because the
the opponents are AI and not actual
people it's about in midnight when I'm
making this video and I'm sadly haven't
found a single brawl match or a tribute
a I
so on the small chance that you actually
can't find a match in those game modes
do a PvP will definitely be a good
substitute
so to recap just in case you got lost
you want to play brawl AI unless you
have a full team before in which case to
play a tribute a I and then you can
clear matches between a minute and
thirty two two minutes and proceed to
get tons of the event rewards hopefully
you guys did find this video helpful
hopefully I got to clear up some of the
confusion surrounding the season five
weapon sets as opposed to the event
weapon sets so hopefully you guys got
that all covered up if you guys do like
the video please sure to give it a like
really does help me out subscribe if
you're new I cover a lot of four on our
news information leaks all the
informational side of for honor I cover
that a lot my two most recent four
hundred video is gonna be on screen if
you guys want to check that out and with
that guys hope you have a great rest
your day enjoy that loot and peace out